So your company has been losing customers and you don't know what else to do.
You've bombarded your customers with a zillion messages:...
...e-mails, postcards, daily deals, Tweets, Facebook messages, text messages.
Unfortunately, these generic and inefficient messages just didn't deliver as promised.
So you invest thousands of dollars in dashboard reports to find...
...actionable insights...
...to understand why customers are leaving.
You're looking at more and more charts every day.
Charts by region, country and customer.
Pie charts.
Bar charts.
Line charts.
Charts you've never seen before.
They look pretty, all right,...
...but having data at your fingertips does not guarantee success.
Finding ways to keep customers coming back to your store...
...is like finding a needle in a haystack.
And it might cost you 787 clicks.
And once that needle is found...
...the customer is long gone.
So, what's the best way to bring customers back to your store?
Mineful.
Mineful integrates with your e-commerce or CRM data and uses statistics...
...to look at your customers' behavior and predict which customers are at risk.
Then it gives you a list of customers you need to get in touch with...
...along with tools to easily communicate with them.
Take this guy.
He runs a business and uses Mineful to connect...
...with his customers when they need him the most.
Now he knows that Mary,...
...who used to purchase 5,000 dollars worth of goods, is off track.
He calls Mary, offers her a discount on a new product and Mary happily purchases.
So we know, we know, you really love your pretty charts.
But really now, isn't it time to take action?
Go to mineful.com and start getting more customers to shop with you again.